senate kamala harris getting mocked and  criticized once again after dishing out  another one of her now notoriously  scrambled responses which her critics  have taken to calling a word salad the  vice president was meeting with the  jamaican prime minister for example and  she blurted this out  for jamaica one of the issues that has  been presented as an issue that is  economic in the way of its impact has  been the pandemic  so to that end we are announcing today  also that we will assist jamaica in  covid recovery um by assisting in terms  of the recovery efforts in jamaica that  have been essential to i believe what is  necessary to strengthen not only  the the the issue of public health but  also the economy  say what they say  you